voir
je te donne dix secondes d'avancé
cherche quoi un déguisement de super
héros du super élégant ça me gratte
pourquoi t'es déguisé en grosse dial
c'est beau à disparaître je veux devenir
invisible
c'est un super héros alors quel garçon
invisible et tu dois sauver toutes les
personnes qui sont en danger qui tient
un fantôme tu as a été du don de ta mère
elle s'est sacrifiée pour te sauver
ils ont enquêté sur nous ils cherchent
peut-être des jeunes qui ont des dons
exceptionnels
tu commence tout juste à maîtriser ton
talent la division c'est que tu es ici
c'est qu'ils tuent existe vraiment
j'ai attendu ce moment toute ma vie ça
fait longtemps qu'on le cherche